it's what the Video Game Awards there
was a reveal a trailer for Mortal Kombat
11 and you know me there are two things
I love in the world Mortal Kombat
another thing so I want to talk about
this because Mortal Kombat's been a part
of my life since life I'm telling you
nothing's better than seeing that Mortal
Kombat symbol come up and hearing the
crowd go [__] bananas which is funny
because this trailer is pretty simple
it's Raiden beating the living piss out
of scorpion but in a world where these
trailers are supposed to reveal
something about the game I feel like if
you look into it you're gonna you're
gonna speculate as a natural course of
action it is the internet after all why
else are we here but I love Mortal
Kombat and injustice NetherRealm Studios
doing a great job with the fighting
games but after injustice and playing
that for so long it's great to come back
to Mortal Kombat be like oh look at the
Gordon grit and ass and blood and
crunching and sounds of cartilage though
there are no signs of x-ray moves in
this trailer they didn't show an x-ray
there are throws and moves that happen
which usually it would show the x-ray
mechanic but they don't show it maybe
they like you know the x-ray eye moves
are in it Raiden is actually like
hardcore red eyes red lightning rate in
the last time we saw that Raiden was a
Mortal Kombat deception because at the
end of Mortal Kombat Deadly Alliance
which was the cutscene at the beginning
of Mortal Kombat deception Raiden does
the comecomecome blows himself up there
when he came back together he was
hardcore red lightning Raiden he was
like you know what my way of being nice
isn't getting it done I'm gonna wreck
some [__] and though it took a different
path at the end of Mortal Kombat X he
has shin ox head and he throws it on the
ground he's like you know what my way of
being nice isn't getting it done I'm
gonna wreck some [__] so he's ended up
there anyway which with time constants
and variables that's a constant I guess
I always wondered what are they gonna
bring Shu Gingka back like I liked you
Gingka he was the protagonist in Mortal
Kombat deception this would be about the
time to bring him in I think it'd be
kind of a cool take to make sure Jenko a
bad guy thinking like yep just raise the
Dragon King and I don't care [__] you
I'm gonna join him now it's a different
timeline you can do different things
though it looks like Raiden might be the
villain in this one I speculate that
he's the villain because he looks pretty
hardcore and hanzo hasashi she's good
now like he broke bread was sub-zero
you're grabbing his head like fraf [__]
he's alright I guess you're not friends
and after scorpion dies another scorpion
comes out of nowhere looking like old
scorpion and he does a Raiden ish
scorpion ish move it's like riding and
scorpion fused together and have their
own move like I briefly saw somewhere
like a headline I didn't even look into
it but edie boon I believe said
something about customization in this
game you can like hardcore customize
your character so I guess that's what
that is it's a
scorpion character that has a retro
outfit that kind of has a Raiden ish
move that's kind of a scorpion ish move
and like the two of fused together and
if you're taking the armor mechanics and
the customizable moves you saw an
injustice dude that would be the next
step up for Mortal Kombat 11 so I
believe that is showing you you can
hardcore customize your characters I
don't know if you can build an all new
character from the ground up like what
they did in mortal kombat armageddon I
believe mortal kombat armageddon was
well-intentioned that was actually a
mechanic I liked in there but if we only
have the options to have fatalities set
in stone and the types of fatalities
they had and mortal kombat armageddon
sat the fatalities in stone those are
better though if this trailer is any
indication as to what we'll see for
fatalities I imagine it's not a problem
because look at that that's [__]
awesome I don't know all I know is that
retrospectively like I wanted a Mortal
Kombat 11 trailer months ago when we
should have had it but I'm glad I didn't
get it then because now I have it now I
don't have to wait too long on pins and
needles before I actually get the game
but comparatively it's not too long it's
just a few months from that but I can't
wait to see what they do a lot of our is
gonna be drowned in the Mortal Kombat 11
when it comes out bring on more we're
calm battle of if I said the trailer for
Mortal Kombat 11 have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]